Je veux que les gens entendent ma
voix [Applaudissements] et oublient leurs problèmes pendant
minutes. Savez-vous ce que signifie le pouvoir des filles
pour rencontrer Sarah Bourn Lauren Hill,
vous devez le savoir. Je ne suis pas un espion
de l'
école primaire pour vendre
des concerts.  ça va arriver un de
ces jours, ta voix est comme la tienne, mais
c'est l'une des meilleures que j'ai jamais connue, c'est
ma fille, c'est mon Amy, j'ai rencontré
quelqu'un ce soir, reste chanceuse,
Amy, j'aurais dû avoir
[Music]
boys, le numéro un de l'album.  l'
album le plus vendu au monde par une
artiste féminine britannique aux
États-Unis
[Applaudissements]
W Je ne pense pas que j'ai été mis sur cette Terre
juste pour me chanter Je veux être une femme Je
veux être une
mère, je m'enfuirai probablement avec quelqu'un  célèbre
de toute façon tu es mon battement de coeur tu es mon
âme je t'aime
[Musique] je
ne me tape pas les locataires avant le déjeuner j'ai
besoin de vivre mes chansons donc c'est ce que je
vais faire
prêt
[Musique]
je ne le fais pas  Je n'écris pas de chansons pour être
célèbre, j'écris des chansons
parce que je dois faire quelque chose de bon avec
quelque chose
de mauvais. [Applaudissements]